when covet first hit you know I like so
many
um had to Pivot my business and we we
had you know serious issues that we had
to face immediately there was no there
was no luxury of time and I called a
friend of mine who's active duty
military and I asked him a very simple
question which is how do I
compartmentalize my emotions so that I
can stay focused on the mission
and he said you can't
and he actually gave me a very Stern
warning he said we can do it for very
very short periods of time he says but
no one escapes the trauma of combat he
says some people go through it many
months after they get back and people
are all confused because everything's
fine and we're familiar and like we know
that we know the score and you're back
home but that's when it starts to show
up and so I called all of my a-type
personality friends and said okay none
of us are going to get through this
without feeling something so we made a
deal that if we started to feel anything
we would call each other and sure enough
um a friend of mine started to go
through it and she called me and we had
you know she's a she's a she's a
well-known CEO and you know went for
long walks and and struggled and we did
it together
um about four or five months into the
the pandemic I started to feel off my
game I started to feel a little burnt
out a little tired a little unmotivated
and so I called that same military
friend and I said by the way what are
your symptoms when you when you start to
suffer trauma and he said I uh I go to
bed late and don't want to get out of
bed in the morning for no particular
reason I went yup he said I'm I have an
uh an unproductive day and I'll
rationalize it like oh that's okay
you're allowed a day of unproductivity
but I'll have another and another and
another and I went yep
and then he said I become really
anti-social I don't want to talk to
anyone and I definitely don't want to
ask anybody for help and I went yup and
what I realized is I was going through
the trauma
um and so I asked him what do you do and
he says you have to force yourself to
get into a sleep habit and you have to
reach out to people for help and that's
what I did I called people and told them
that I was struggling
um and I came up with a rule that
there's no crying alone
that if you feel overwhelmed you just
pick up the phone and call somebody say
can I just talk and I think the thing
that gets us through this is is the
quality of our relationships quite
frankly
um and and if the company talks about
these things it makes it that it removes
the stigma if somebody calls somebody
else up and says I'm struggling today